makes me happy somebody pulled up
spectrometric science thanks for
inviting me and being here um this is
joint work with Charlie who's my student
over there another student and all these
people that are not really existing
anymore
okay and maybe this will be a short talk
because I have to move my car so I don't
know you know we'll see how this goes
okay so I'm serious like I got the $70
ticket last time in some situation like
this okay so hopefully everybody knows
about how to represent graphs via
adjacency matrices this is pretty common
in all aspects of mathematics and
computer science
you know whenever there is an edge with
some weight you create this matrix an
entry IJ corresponding to nodes I and J
has an entry with that weight inside
there this is an adjacency matrix and
since it's a linear operator it has
eigenvalues and eigenvectors like linear
operators do we call the spectrum the
set of eigenvalues usually ordered in
decreasing order lambda 1 through lambda
N and spectrographs have received a lot
of attention from both theory and
practice of computer science the most
sort of important reason why this had
happened in my opinion is their
relationship with partitioning
clustering cutting graphs and in
practice this has a lot of applications
in network reliability you know if you
want to build a road you want to kind of
like your network to be well connected
so that when one bridge fails the two
parts don't just all of a sudden become
disconnected and you can go from one
place to another community detection in
facebook etc etc and this is captured by
what we call the relationship between
spectrum and sparse Escott sparse cut
for those of you who don't know it's
just the minimum ratio over all
partitions of the graph of the edges
crossing the partition over the smallest
size of the cut the
is that and I don't know where the
clicker that is that it try it out
that's it okay so yeah so this is a
sparse escape and the celebrated theorem
by Tigger relates the spectrum of this
adjacency matrix with a sparse Eska why
do we want to do that sparse escape is a
quantity that unfortunately is np-hard
to fine
so even though all these applications
that I mentioned would like to find the
sparse s cut so that to make sure there
are no sparse cuts or so that they
cluster communities in facebook or
whichever other application you want you
cannot do that efficiently since it's
np-hard
unless P is equal to NP and chiggers
inequality is kind of like the nest the
next best thing
it says that if I already look at this
linear operator and its second eigen
value which I did not by lambda 2 and
this is for D regular graph but it holds
for any there is a version for any
degree then this D minus lambda 2 is a
very good approximation of this np-hard
quantity I wanted to find this process
cut so I'm going through all this very
quickly because it's most of you know
this already and it's irrelevant to what
I want to talk about so what I'm gonna
look at today is kind of like resembling
this adjacency matrix representation of
graphs that we had only you know okay
you use graphs or matrices to represent
let's say social networks or any-any
graph like the facebook graph here and
you put this edge between a and B if a
and B are friends this is what we
already talked about but what we didn't
talk about is like okay let's say a B
our friends on Facebook but they're you
know Republican and Democrat and they
really dislike each other and you know
they post all these mean comments that
you see sometimes between the I mean I
have two Republican friends I think
we're completely different what we post
but you know it could be the other way
around then you're like okay what if a
and we dislike each other how do you
capture this and the this got suggested
already the 50s I think by Harare first
to capture this dislike 'no seven if a
and b are friends and they're supposed
to be an edge between entries a and B of
the
of this matrix you put a minus 1 instead
of a 1 so if and we like each other
there is a entry with you know with 1 in
this matrix if every dislike each other
there is a minus 1 and we call this the
signed adjacency matrix of a particular
graph denoted by a of s and it would be
assigned adjacency matrix for any
signing so any number of entries could
have minus 1 it could be but what we
talk about today is about symmetric
symmetric matrices in particular so yeah
this is very possible but it's much
harder to analyze mathematically so I'm
not going to talk about history ok so
this is the sign that Jason C matrix
this is where it came from
already as I said in the 50s I think but
why would we care why am I talking about
this even today so recently there was I
mean not so recently anymore I guess
there was this this program by mostly
dan Spillman mcil Srivastava and Adam
Marcus that they were trying to prove
that keratin singer conjecture which
they eventually did but in the process
of this they showed something about
expander graphs so this quickly for
those of you who don't know what
expander grafts are and Ramanujan
expanders in particular we looked at
this lambda 2 that approximates parses
cut so graphs that don't have sparse
cuts graphs that are very well connected
anywhere you cut them or expander graphs
and you know it's kind of like clear why
you would want those for example if you
think about the road application I gave
you the network needs to be well
connected so there are no ways to
separate the network and all of the
sudden it it has some problems so expand
the graphs are graphs with no sparse
cuts in other words their graphs were
lambda 2 the second eigenvalue of the
adjacency matrix is as far away from
lambda 1 as possible lambda 1 for d
regular graphs is always d so lambda 2
has to be
far away from the as possible and the
furthest away it is the better the
expander is that we can see with
chiggers inequality okay so it has been
a really interesting question in
mathematics can we you know do those
graphs even exist what's the best lamb
that - one can get and I'm not going to
get into much of this but it turns out
4d regular graphs the best lamb that you
can get is two square root of D minus
one so let me write this down here since
this is a hearing by LAN bopanna London
has to be at least that much and it
turns out that there are graphs that
achieved this they're called Ramanujan
graphs and for the purposes of this talk
we would call them the best possible
expanders because they achieve the best
possible bound on lambda 2 so this
program by Markus peel - Avast OVA
showed that there exist these graphs for
any possible degree before their work
the only exists tential result that was
there I was by loboteca Phillips and
saranac that show that if the degrees
primer some prime power then you can
construct Ramanujan graphs for those
specific degrees but then this more
general thing by Markus pure and subasta
became where they said yes they exist
Romanism graphs for all degrees and the
way to do that
they did it with what we call a to lift
so a lift of a graph we'll see in a
second is just a bigger graph so you
start from from a good really small
graph let's say the complete graph on
five nodes and then you lift it we I'll
explain what lifting operation is and
you hope to preserve the eigenvalues so
complete graph is the best possible
expander if you lift it and nothing
changes the eigenvalues remain bounded
then you have a bigger graph that's best
possible expander and then you lift it
again etc etc eventually construct
arbitrary families of Ramanujan graphs
by lifting so what we showed is that
there exists always a to lift of a graph
that achieves this Ramanujan bomb and
then we also used lifts to for
quasi-polynomial time algorithms to
construct almost Ramanujan graphs so
there's a lot of and there are other
results that I'm not mentioning here a
literature on yes
well if you want to eventually have
Ramanujan graph we will see in a second
but in general I mean the result I show
this independent of that but if you put
it together you need the graph that you
start with to be Ramanujan for the end
graph to be Ramanujan because the old
egg in values always live okay so and
see here's what to lift art and you will
see that this is exactly signings and
signed adjacency matrices so a to lift
is a graph that has exactly twice as
many nodes as the original graph and
what I do is if the original graph had
an edge you know and so to lift is
exactly assigning I start with a graph
that has an edge between I and J and I
have two choices so I put instead of one
vertex to very rare disease two vertices
for every vertex and I have two choices
one is the plus one signing which would
correspond to a matching between these
two and two vertices that's what we call
the identity matching or the cross so if
I lift an edge this operation is called
lifting and edge according to what you
see on your left this corresponds to a
plus one in the sign that Jason C matrix
and according if I lift it like this
this corresponds to a minus one in the
sign that this yeah it's not much you
know what's the word it split fine so I
replace the way to where this is yeah
split into vertices
let's say it's unweighted but yeah you
can the way to remain the same you know
every edge would have W IJ in here but
let's say now it's unweighted so the new
graph just has instead of one edge it
has two edges so if this was vertex I
this was vertex J I split vertex PI into
two versus I split vertex J two vertices
there was one edge between I and then I
have two edges between this couple of
vertices and the two edges could look
like this or could look like this these
are the two options that you have and it
turns out that this signed adjacency
matrix that
we saw so if you just take those choices
those signs and you write down the sign
that this is a matrix like we saw before
with the Facebook example is all you
need to guarantee or figure out I guess
whether or not your lift is the
Ramanujan graph or not the reason is
because the adjacency matrix of the
bigger graph that has 2n vertices can be
written like this and it's not very hard
to see by this expression either this is
correct
which I'm not gonna so and be that the
set of eigenvalues of this lift graph is
the union of the eigen values of the
original adjacency and the sign
adjacency so sign matrices and signings
of adjacency matrices became popular
I think lately more so because of this
connection that if you were able to
bound the eigenvalues of a s to make
them as small as possible then you will
be able to construct the manners and
graphs so here's a type of question that
would be enough in order to present a
polynomial time algorithm to construct
such graphs because all these results
are existential and we still don't know
how to find a lift efficiently that
achieves the bow that's guaranteed by
the theorem and I have to say that
Michael Cohen had a result that makes
one of their proofs constructive but it
doesn't have to do anything with lift so
I'm not going to go into that so however
let's look at the following problem
we call it bounded eigenvalue signing
i'm giving a real symmetric matrix and
some number lambda some real number and
the question is is there a symmetric
signing of this matrix such that the
largest eigenvalue of the sign version
of this matrix is that most lambda and
if i could solve this problem
efficiently then i could you know and
constructively let's say then I could
find the Ramanujan graph because I said
lambda to be to redo minus 1 and and I
have my answer there so one thing that
we show in this in this work is that
this problem is np-hard
which kind of kills and approach along
those lines too for efficient algorithms
for a management graphs any questions so
however this is not one what I want to
focus on even though that was original
motivation for this problem too we
started trying to find an algorithm to
build Ramanujan graphs and we were stuck
majorly an algorithm long those lines we
ended up proving this is np-hard
and then we started asking other
questions about graph signings so for
example given a real symmetric matrix M
is there and off diagonal signing
symmetric again such that you know the M
of this signed at a symmetric is non
singular in other words the determinant
of it is nonzero or all the eigen values
but there is no eigenvalue that's equal
to zero
and we ended up also resolving this and
I'll give you a motivation for why this
is this is interesting so let's look at
the well-known randomized algorithm for
bipartite matching so this is due to
love us in the 60s I think it's based on
polynomial identity testing by as
follows
so we construct the matrix that's called
the TAT matrix of the graph this is a
matrix where every edge is replaced by a
variable X IJ the specific matrix was
skew symmetric so X IJ is minus XJ I and
a result by that says that the
determinant of this matrix is not
identically 0 so it's not V 0 polynomial
if and only if there exists a perfect
matching in G so the graph is bipartite
and we're trying to design a randomized
algorithm to check to check whether or
not there exists a perfect matching in
this bipartite graph
okay so here is a randomized algorithm
that implied by this theorem so we can
choose X IJ randomly from the real
numbers evaluate the determinant
polynomial of the stat matrix and you
know with probability one I will not hit
roots of this polynomial if I choose X
IJ from the real numbers thus this you
know we get the correct answer with
probability one however we need infinite
randomness to do it you know properly
choose from the real numbers what what
people have done what lovers did was
instead we we choose you know which is
some finite field let's call it s and we
choose elements r1 through RN from this
finite field evaluate the polynomial on
these values from this finite field and
if I get 0 I return answer it's the 0
polynomial if I don't get zero return
answer is not V 0 polynomial and by
sward zipper Lima I know that you know
the probability that a non zero non
identically zero polynomial evaluates to
0 with this random choice is less than
or equal to D over s where is the degree
of the polynomial and s is the size of
the field so this would give us for the
determinant we have a polynomial in M
variables one for edge degrees n so it's
enough to choose a field of size 2n to
get probability of error less than 1/2
so this this theorem by that you know
could be mind to a randomized algorithm
by using that much randomness you know
log n times n m to choose you know one
of the Exide days from the field s of
size 2n so why these signings come into
play is like here's a natural question
forget about choosing a field of sight
from a field of size 2n can we just
choose from f2 what if I restrict my
excited choice is to just be minus 1 1
is this still true that I can choose
random minus 1 1 for every variable
evaluate the determinant of this matrix
and get the correct answer with high
probability so okay so now we consider
the symmetric version of this matrix not
the skew symmetric but this is just a
detail so what we can show is that in
some sense this is indeed true so if
there is a perfect matching in this
bipartite graph then there is always
going to be a signing that makes the
determinant nonzero so this polynomial
won't be the zero polynomial however the
probability of success of this can be
exponentially low
I'll get to that yeah you read the head
okay so but this is sort of the yeah
this is the first step to a more general
result that says that not necessarily
bipartite or an arbitrary graph G for
any graph G the determinant of a saw
every signed matrix of this graph is 0
if and only if the support graph of sir
I mean yeah okay so for any foreigner
betray graph G every signing of the
adjacency matrix of Z has determinant
equal to 0 if and only if the graph does
not have a perfect two matching so what
is it perfect two matching real quickly
instead of just having matching edges
you can have cycles so every every node
still has degree 2 and it's either
because it will it has two edges
belonging to a cycle or because it has
like a back and forth loop so perfect
two matching is a generalization of
matching where you're allowed to cover
all the vertices by either using cycles
or matching edges okay so the theorem
says that the only way for all the
possible signings of the adjacency
matrix to be singular is if there is no
perfect two matching in the graph so now
here's a theorem which hopefully
probably all of you know it's the alums
version of northland so it's a
combinatorial nullstellensatz ed if I
have a multivariate polynomial and I
have a term in this polynomial the
degree of each variable on this term is
ti and this is the non identically 0
polynomial then I give you any set s1
through SN e collection of sets s1
through SN but with the promise that si
size is bigger than ti where TI was the
degree of variable X I then I know I am
guaranteed that there is a topple from
this collection of set
such that the polynomial evaluates to
non zero okay so basically this is an
extension of if I had one variable and I
give you know a polynomial of degree D
and I give you D plus 1 points then I
could find a nonzero among those D plus
1 points and this is the multi
multivariate version of this of this
thing and this has been a powerful
algebraic tool to show existence of
certain combinatorial structures it's
similar along the lines of lovers local
lemma in Spencer's discrepancy theorem
for example by applying this for the
correct polynomial you can prove that
every simple for regular graph contains
a three regular sub graph and you can do
that for other degrees and stuff too I
just have the simplest version here
however in contrast to Lover's local
Emma and Spencer there is no known
constructive proof of C n Combinator and
not still answer I'll call it C and
because it's hard to say the whole thing
okay so in fact the alone and and west
and other people have wondered about the
you know whether one can make
combinatorial not cylinder constructive
because you know the other two things
that we know how to prove existence of
structures have been made constructive
and there was recently a result that
shows that this problem is PPA complete
under some circuit input models for
polynomials but I won't get into that
much what I do want to get into is that
the proof of this theorem first of all
follows from combinatorial
nullstellensatz of this theorem and the
second thing that I hope to get to talk
to if I have a little bit of time is
that not only we can prove this theorem
by CN but we can also make it
constructive so in particular if the
polynomial is a determinant polynomial
then I can find a non non zero of this
polynomial in polynomial time among you
know the field of two elements so
or five minutes fish
okay let me try to finish and not get a
ticket at the same time so let's define
let's try to see how we prove this
define this polynomial which is nothing
but a restatement of the determinant
polynomial so determinant can be written
as the sum over all permutations of the
sign of a permutation and the terms that
correspond to the permutation and is not
hard to see that the only terms that
survive our terms that belong to perfect
to matchings otherwise there would be
some zero entry you know if the graph is
not if the term is not covering a
perfect to matching cycles or matching
edges and I can write this polynomial
for some fixed coefficients that are
what you get from the determinant and
consider now this polynomial the first
claim is that the polynomial is
identically 0 if and only if the set of
perfect two matchings is empty and
that's not very hard to see one
direction the other direction let's
consider the set of perfect matchings is
not empty then and pick F in the set of
perfect to matchings then there is a
term a monomial that has nonzero
coefficient that corresponds to this
perfect two matching and moreover if
there are other terms other monomials
that have the same variables in them
they would have the same sign this is
also not very hard to see because they
have the same cycle edges and the sign
of a permutation depends on the cycle
edges so consider this proved Amanda I
just went to it very fast so if F is
identically 0 if and only if the set of
perfect matchings is empty and now let's
let's prove this other theorem by
Knowles to lanza ok so if there is a
perfect you might think there is this
term here and there variables with
exponent either 0 1 so the degree of its
variable is either 0 1 we know there is
maximum degree nonzero coefficient term
immediately apply nail salons ax for sis
to be the set minus one comma one note
that every variable has degree 0 1 and
the size of the set is 2 so it's bigger
than 0 or 1 so we're in the right
setting and you know that's the proof
so again unfortunately we would like a
constructive way to prove CN but we
don't have any so let's start
restricting ourselves to special cases
like what if my polymer is a determinant
polynomial can I find a non zero in
polynomial time it turns out I can and
I'm just gonna speak like 30 seconds of
how to do this it's a recursive
algorithm that uses a generalized
version of 2 matching which is a cycle
cover cycle cover is between 2 possibly
different sets of vertices x and y and
it looks like this so in the common
thing it's cycles loops or edges and in
the between you know the the nodes in X
but not in Y and Y but not in X their
paths could be edges or any any length
paths so this is a cycle cover and there
is a generalization of of this other
theorem that the determinant there is
assigning with nonzero determinant of
this sub matrix M of s restricted to X&Y
rows and columns if and only if there is
a an X Y cycle cover and there is a way
to make this constructive and by this
constructive proof of this theorem you
get immediately a recursive algorithm
that reduces the size of of my graph
that I'm looking for by one edge row by
two vertices
every time and
okay I think I'm right on time thank you
[Applause]
you see a little bit more about that
actually no I mean it's way beyond it's
a circuit complexity model that I have
nothing to do with I was gonna sell the
open problems thank you for reminding me
okay so here's a bunch of open problems
one of the important open problems is
you know okay we know that an input
model that's P P P P a complete is there
like any generalized input model that's
also useful in some sense that admits
you know we can make it constructive so
this is I think the most important open
question in which cases can you make C
and constructive
I mean clearly if you given the
monomials explicitly then we're fine but
what representation of polynomials that
you're not giving them or normals
explicitly are interesting yes special
case for determinants that you consider
and does it fall under PP a the
algorithm you have it's polynomial time
so you can find it already yeah does
that answer your question this special
class I mean it's not beating that
non-constructive net result by coming up
at a different technique it's still
within that class but it's beating
because it's a special case I mean the
input model is the friend I can't
compare the input models because I'm not
very well-versed in circuit input models
for polynomials so but I can compare
like how much if the one is a special
case of the other if there's
determinants that cannot be given like
this I'm not sure but nonetheless
identifying which input models can make
C and constructive I think it's
important and then even if we cannot do
that for example can we find three
regular graphs of degree 4 3 regular sub
graphs of degree 4 graphs so the
applications of CN can we make those
constructive by looking at those
polynomials
give you I mean these are important open
problems in graph theory and if we have
a general recursive algorithm ake
anything constructive for C n we might
be able to solve this important problems
in graph theory even if we don't answer
the first question and then you know
there thinks about expanders that need
to be answered but again this is a
different topic
[Applause]